like mother like son  Princess Diana's legacy was brought full  circle when Harry donned the distinctive  blue body armor of the halo trust 22  years ago Diana took a similar path  across an Angolan field scattered with  deadly landmines left over from years of  Civil War it became one of the most  iconic images of her short life she was  campaigning to rid the world of these  weapons but never lived to see her  success she died just months before an  international treaty banned land mines  in December 1997 but over two decades  later the world is still not free of  these devices and echoing his mother  loud and clear Prince Harry detonated a  recently detected mined land mines an  unhealed by clearing the land mines we  can help this community find peace and  with peace risking death to save lives  may not be what a mother dreams of for  her son but this son would have made his  mother so very proud for CBS this  morning I'm Debora patta in Cape Town  South Africa